this is it as soon as Tim gets back
we're ready to release
Hazel
2023.1 is what we've decided to call it
it's the first release for 2023
it's our first release I think in
general I haven't really done releases
before
[Music]
[Applause]
alive
[Music]
looking so beautiful I don't
know
everyone put a light on your phone and
hold it in the air all right
so this is the studio Channel Hazel
GitHub repository this is the master
branch
and nine months ago nine months
how long it takes to make a child
uh is how long it's been since we
released Hazel last so um we're going to
uh
do the release now so everything that we
kind of have that we've been working on
is in Dev you can see that there's
commits going in like an hour ago uh
it's 504 commits ahead of Master that's
how long it's been
um so we're now going to kind of merge
that in and I could there's so many
different ways to do this I'm probably
just going to open a pull request which
is uh and the reason why I'm doing it
this way is because I've actually never
done it this way before so I'm all about
trying something new so here we are
we're gonna open up a pull request
um we're going to basically merge uh I
guess like enter master from like Dev
obviously
let's compare the changes it's able to
merge they can be automatically merged
which of course makes sense and that's
504 commits 756 files changed
lots of zero X apparently this is like
all just zero X
I actually don't know like what the deal
is
it are these commits yeah right
yeah I think no I I it's not it's not
it's time based it's just that I think
that was a period where Xerox is working
on animation in Dev because remember
this is Dev Branch so this is not all
the branches we were usually working on
our own individual branches but I guess
they're actually just working off of Dev
or something
anyway either way create pulled request
hold this
Hazel release
2023.1 the comment is going to be one of
these emojis
and we'll create the pull request
these are the reviewers that it's
suggesting we request but that's not
going to happen yeah so there you go
um
pretty cool
pretty decent 423
000 lines of code are added and 21 000
removed
so that is what we've been up to for the
last nine months for those of you who
think that we haven't been doing
anything because I just it's funny like
the amount of patrons that check out
like the get access to Hazel and then
the first thing they check out is Master
which is like you know I mean that is
the default branch of the repository so
I'm not blaming them but the point is
they checked that out and they're like
oh yeah there hasn't been any changes in
nine months so they have been you just
need to not be on the master Branch
because the Masters like our release
branch which I'm probably going to
rename to release to be fair moving
forward and then we're going to uh try
and do these once a quarter is the idea
so at the moment we do them once three
quarters I guess it's been nine months
since the last one but this is the first
one right so we're gonna try and do them
like every quarter and then if you want
kind of like the latest code that is
still more or less stable so not like
actual work in progress that doesn't
even compile then that's all going to be
in the dev Branch so that's kind of how
we organize this
um so yeah this is open so since I am
also the owner of this I'll just merge
the board request
um
match
from Dev confirm match
and it is done
that is scary the release has been
shipped
uh if we go back here then yeah that's
the master branch
just dunsies
so yeah we should probably update the
readme
um
but yeah
Tada we should celebrate
we already had a cake though for Peter's
birthday recently so I don't want
another cake
but yay the release is done are you
excited Tim I am
sure Tim's expression
what it's been released
mind-blowing
it is
a software developer I'm not an actor